Americans used to be the biggest movers in the industry.
Now, it's the Chinese.
Last year, more Chinese people traveled...
...and spent more money doing so than any other nationality.
As middle classes get wealthier across emerging market countries,...
...so too do their travel budgets.
Although only seven percent of Chinese citizens own a passport,...
...by 2030, Chinese trips will account for around a quarter of international tourism.
Thailand is the top international destination for Chinese travelers.
Mexico is the number one choice for residents of the United States,...
...but Europeans tend to stay in Europe.
Around 90% of nights spent by tourists in the EU are by European residents.
Europe is the most visited continent,...
...and France the most visited country in the world.